[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> FOR DECADES THE "STAR TREK"
FRANCHISE HAS BROUGHT YOU
UNFORGETTABLE VOYAGES FROM THE
FINAL FRONTIER.
NOW, THE TRADITION CONTINUES
WITH A NEW SHIP, A NEW CREW, AND
A NEW CAPTAIN.
AMAZON FOUNDER JEFF BEZOS.
>> SPACE IS FREAKING AWESOME.
>> "STAR TREK: EGO QUEST" THE
VOYAGES OF THE S.S. NEW
SHEPPARD.
AND HIS CREW OF RANDOM WEIRDOES.
CAPTAIN JEFF BEZOS.
>> HELL YES.
>> FIRST MATE JEFF BEZOS'
BROTHER WHOSE NAME IS --
SCIENCE OFFICER SOME RANDOM RICH
HIGH SCHOOL KID FROM THE
NETHERLANDS
>> WHOA!
WHOA!
WE HIT A SPACE STATION.
>> OOPS, DON'T CARE.
>> BUT AROUND EVERY CORNER,
DANGER LURKS.
>> INCOMING TORPEDO!
>> WHO THE HELL'S FIRING AT US?
>> HELLO, JEFF BEZOS.
>> ELON MUSK.
YOU SON OF A BITCH.
>> SO, SPACE IS ONLY BIG ENOUGH
FOR ONE WEIRD WHITE BILLIONAIRE.
SO YOU CAN SAY BEATING YOU IS MY
PRIME OBJECTIVE.
>> THEY'LL NEED ALL THE HELP
THEY CAN GET FROM A LOYAL TEAM
OF VALUED EMPLOYEES.
>> WOW.
>> CAPTAIN, WE HAVE A REQUEST TO
BEAM ONBOARD.
>> OKAY.
BEAM HIM UP.
SPACE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M UP HERE.
>> ADIOS.
>> BY THE WAY, IT'S AN HONOR TO
MEET YOU, SIR.
PEOPLE SAY YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE AMAZON EMPLOYEES, BUT I
DISAGREE.
OH, WOW, JUST GOING TO THROW ME
OUT LIKE THAT.
CAN I USE THE BATHROOM REAL
QUICK?
HEY, MAN, I'M NOT PEEING IN
THIS!
>> "STAR TREK: EGO QUEST"
STREAMING THIS CHRISTMAS.
>> WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
WE DO A COUPLE LAPS?